[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: I have with me this afternoon John White,
who is the State Superintendent of Education for the state of Louisiana.
He was the Deputy Chancellor for the New York City school systems.
So he's had a lot of experience with a broad range of organizations
and positions in education.
And currently, he's the Chair of the Chiefs
for Change, an organization of state chief officers
who are committed to reform in American education.
And I'm very pleased to have the opportunity
to talk with him today about the amazing developments that
have been occurring in Louisiana.
Louisiana has always been a low performing state.
But in recent years, under John White's leadership,
this state has made more progress than any other state in the United States,
according to the National Assessment of Educational Progress.
And it all starts, perhaps, with Katrina,
the great hurricane in New Orleans.
Because that washed away the preexisting school system.
So John, that's what I'd like to really ask you about.
How did it happen that a new school system was built out of--
shall I say-- the ashes of-- or at least the mud and the sludge
of the Katrina storm.
JOHN WHITE: A great tragedy--
of course, we call it a man-made tragedy in New Orleans.
But prior to Katrina, New Orleans, by any measure,
was the lowest performing urban school system in the country.
It was the second lowest performing school system
in the second lowest performing state in America.
When you have to vacate your entire city for weeks and months,
and sometimes even years, for many of our people, you have no students.
When you have no students, you have no revenue for a school board.
And when that happened, the school board in New Orleans in 2005,
tragically, severed its contract with its teachers.
And the state stepped in and said, well, we
will then take over the governance of every school in New Orleans, which
is struggling academically.
And that was nearly 90% of the schools.
Over time, the state transitioned those schools
from being run by the state to being operated by independent charter school
organizations.
That took many, many years.
But it took a decade.
And now we are where we are, with a system
that is almost exclusively independent charter schools.
PROFESSOR: Well, actually, you had a little help, I think.
That's what I've heard.
And maybe you could tell me, were there some outside resources
that became available, simply because the tragedy captured
national attention?
Did foundations come in?
JOHN WHITE: No question.
I mean, New Orleans is a city that is at the heart of the American identity.
It's a city that, whenever you mention, people have smiles across their faces.
And it's also a city of great poverty.
And philanthropic interests know that, from across the country,
as well as from within Louisiana.
Also, people, in a range of issues, from blight and Urban Development issues,
all the way to education and health issues, came to Louisiana--
I count myself as one of them--
to help with what I think of as a reformation,
but not just of a school system since a storm--
really, of tragedies that have befallen low income people in Louisiana
and in the South for centuries.
And that's what our project is about.
But no question about it.
Both people from the inside and people from the outside were part of this.
PROFESSOR: Young people came, too, didn't they?
Didn't young teachers from around the country
feel it was sort of their moral obligation to go to New Orleans
and help out during this time of stress?
JOHN WHITE: Yeah, I think there was a missionary feel to it.
Certainly, I view it as a moral calling.
At the same time, it also gave rise to a whole generation
of New Orleans who had, as is the case in New York or anywhere else,
existed within a school board establishment that's
very hard to be creative within, and very hard to be upwardly mobile in.
So there are a lot of veteran New Orleans educators
who are now able to run schools that they always wanted to run.
And they're able to do it in a charter school system, where
they work for a volunteer board, rather than for an elected
board and superintendent.
PROFESSOR: So this released a lot of internal energy
as well as bringing in external energy.
JOHN WHITE: Yeah, no question about it.
And over the last 10 years, we've been finding our way to,
how do you give life to local voices?
How do you recruit the right outside voices?
And how, when you recruit outside voices,
do you make sure that the things that are important to us in New Orleans--
music, for example, and the arts--
incredibly important to the identity of people in New Orleans,
and to their upbringings-- how do you make sure
that you never lose those things, even when you have outside talent?
PROFESSOR: And the federal government helped with some building of schools?
Was that part of the asset that you were able to work with?
JOHN WHITE: It doesn't hurt.
It doesn't hurt.
Every child, now, is in a renovated or a fully reconstructed building--
some amazing buildings.
The school where Ruby Bridges went to school in New Orleans,
we have totally rebuilt--
preserved the facade and preserved her classroom.
It's amazing the resources that came into New Orleans
after that great tragedy.
And of course those were opportunities for the next generation of kids
as much as they were tragedies for many of the kids who were there.
We also benefited from an investment in innovation
that the federal government-- the Obama administration,
rather than the Bush administration, in this case-- made,
to grow high performing charter organizations.
So we've done some good things.
We've certainly had a lot of help along the way.
It's not resources that every city has at their disposal.
But it's also fair to say that the principles of it--
independent schools, recruiting talent-- those are things that anybody can do.
PROFESSOR: Well, is there any good evidence that all of this
has paid off-- that students are actually
learning more today than they had been in the days
before all of this renovation took place?
JOHN WHITE: One of the things we're also blessed with
is, it wasn't just educators, but it was political scientists and economists
who came to Louisiana.
They wanted to study this stuff, too.
In fact, Tulane has started a center run by an economist named Doug Harris.
And economists got together and studied the effects, in multiple ways,
of what's happened in Louisiana, and in New Orleans, specifically,
and have concluded that, statistically, no school system that those researchers
are aware of has demonstrated the effect on student achievement
in such a short period of time than have New Orleans schools.
I do want to be clear, though.
We have a long, long way to go.
New Orleans has gone from the bottom of the state in Louisiana
to around the median in the state of Louisiana,
which, given its poverty rate and other things, is an incredible thing.
But it's not nearly at the top of our state.
And our state still performs relatively low in the national rankings.
So we have a long, long way to go.
PROFESSOR: Well, Louisiana has also enacted a school voucher program.
So it's a statewide school voucher program, I think.
It has its component in New Orleans, but elsewhere throughout the state.
How has that worked out?
JOHN WHITE: Well, it's shown a lot of good, positive effects.
It's shown positive effects in terms of greater integration of schools.
It's shown positive effects in terms of parent approval.
It's begun to show positive effects in initial research,
in terms of the effect of having greater levels of competition.
So kids, in other schools in proximity to the voucher schools, are doing well.
And we'll have research coming out soon that I
think will demonstrate that the voucher schools right now are performing
on a par with schools in the rest of the system.
That said, for me, it's not about whether it's
a private school, a charter school, or a traditional public school-- it's just,
is it a good school?
My view is, we should measure them all, give parents access to all of them,
and that the system will be better for parents having that choice, provided
that we can validate that there's good work going on in those schools.
PROFESSOR: Well, the overall system in Louisiana is moving forward.
What do you attribute that to?
JOHN WHITE: It's a simple formula.
This stuff is not rocket science.
But it's actually having access to early childhood education.
It's having benchmarks, standards, and assessments, and curriculum.
And curriculum matters.
I have to say that.
It's having prepared teachers, who are prepared in the classroom,
not in the ivory tower--
a pathway to prosperity for every graduate,
and revitalizing our career and technical education system--
and then, finally, not being afraid to intervene.
When things are really going off the rails--
and typically, in our country, that affects low-income kids of color--
you can't be afraid to intervene.
And so we're looking at Baton Rouge, and doing work
in Shreveport and other cities, where there
are high concentrations of struggling schools in low-income neighborhoods.
That's not something that we can tolerate.
And you have to be willing to do something about it.
PROFESSOR: So you're the head of Chiefs for Change, which
is trying to introduce reforms throughout the country,
working together with other people who are like you--
the head of the educational system in that state.
So how can you export what you're learning in Louisiana?
How does it work when you are working with an organization like that?
JOHN WHITE: Well, Chiefs for Change is a group of-- there's a handful of us who
are State Chiefs--
Mississippi, New Mexico, Nevada, Massachusetts, the Washington,
DC State Superintendent.
So we've got a good mix of state chiefs.
We've also got district chiefs.
In our system-- the fragmented American education system--
you have to have both on board.
You can't have the state and the district
working consistently at odds with one another.
And so we have huge district superintendents
that are doing amazing things, from California all the way to Florida,
in our group, too.
We have formed working groups to take on what we think
are the greatest challenges coming up.
One of them is, how should schools be governed
in times when the current governing structure is not working?
What should be done?
And I think that's an incredibly powerful question, given everything
that we've tried that's worked, based on research over the last 10 years,
under No Child Left Behind, and Race to the Top.
But also there's a lot that hasn't worked.
And there's a lot of wasted money and wasted activity.
And so that's one example of how we can work together to say,
this is what we're committed to doing together.
PROFESSOR: Well, so let me be specific about that.
How about the New Orleans model, where every school is a school of choice?
Is that something that should be put into place in other big cities
around the country?
JOHN WHITE: And we're experiencing this, of course,
in Massachusetts, as we have this dialogue that there
is a referendum on the ballot regarding, are charter schools a good thing?
And the research in Massachusetts would demonstrate without question
that they are.
In Louisiana, it would demonstrate without question that they are.
And there are other places, though, where charter schools have really
struggled.
So it's not just, is an all charter school system a good thing?
I mean, let's be honest.
Look at Detroit.
It's not working at the scale that it needs
to work at-- at the quality it needs to work at.
So can it be done well?
Yes, if there is a plan to have talent, to
have accountability, to have the right governance model,
to offer options to families, and to intervene when schools don't do well.
If you have those things in place, it can work.
And there's research now in Massachusetts,
in Louisiana, and elsewhere, to demonstrate that it can work.
But it's not just charter schools.
It's having a plan for who runs them, and what to do when they don't work.
PROFESSOR: No magic bullet is going to solve
the problem of American education.
JOHN WHITE: Absolutely not.
No question.
PROFESSOR: John, this has been a great opportunity
for me to discuss our schools and where we need to go.
Thank you very much for joining me today.
JOHN WHITE: Fun for me, as well.
Thanks, Paul.
PROFESSOR: Thanks.